you can see the absolute devastation
here in butcher left by the fighting as
russian forces were beaten back the
wreckage of russian vehicles is
littering this street and also you can
see the damage to the houses around
right now today there are a lot of
ukrainian military here um there's we've
seen demining going on there's a big
attempt to start trying to clear up this
town residents as well coming out but
there's still no power there's no water
here it's going to take an awful long
time for life to get any sign of
normality and all the while there is the
concern that yes while russian forces
have pulled back are they pulling back
just to regroup and maybe to attack
again
this is the street where a number of
bodies were found just abandoned on the
road and we've been talking to
a few residents from that apartment
block over there and we just found them
standing in the street and i started
talking to them and it just gives you a
sense of how
literally everybody here has a horror
story to tell one woman i spoke to
described how she saw russian soldiers
who came to their apartment building
asking one of her neighbors to show them
his documents this man she said that he
was nearly 50. he went to go and find
his documents but as he went to go and
find them she says that she saw the
russian soldiers shoot him in the back
of the head she then took us around the
back of the apartment block where on the
ground the neighbors have have dug three
graves where they buried this man and
two others who they say were shot by
russian soldiers